hello everyone and welcome to a game
from round seven of this year's Global
chess League I'm referring to it uh you
know merely as a game uh you guys said
that even seeing what kind of a game it
was that was spoiling uh uh the The
Experience too much so I'm just gonna
call it a game uh versus Magnus Carlson
two former World classical Champions to
uh World rapid Champions uh it's uh you
know it's a game let's check it out and
before we do uh just wondering if there
are any fans of the Final Fantasy
franchise have you tried Final Fantasy
16 and what do you what is your take on
it uh I'm currently in the uh trying it
out so I I would like to know uh what do
you think about it uh so let's dive
straight into the game now Anand has the
wine pieces and he opens with not with
that with Ponte E4 uh we have Pawn the
E6 Magnus goes for the French defense D4
we have Pawn to D5 and Knight to C3 uh
we have Bishop to B4 the winiver
variation of the French and now Ponte E5
so they are just battling it out in the
in the main line c5d Advanced variation
we have A3 or rather countering the
advanced variation with C5 with A3
Bishop captures and c3b captures and
Knight the C6 all very standard stuff
here uh Queen to G4 and now Pawn to G6
with Pawn to H4 by Anan this is uh uh
well not a new or anything that has been
played many times before but it's not
the uh absolute Mainline like Knight to
F3 is more of a uh well more of a common
move here Ponte for Queen to D1 those
are the standard moves but they want the
H4 I I would be like the fourth most
popular continuation it's okay Pawn to
H6 and now uh Anand continues with Pawn
to H5 which is interesting as he won a
very nice game against Ruslan Polo Mario
in 2007 also with the white pieces in
this position where he played Bishop to
D2 but here he switches the move order a
little bit he plays Spawn to H5 G5 Now
Pawn to F4 I'm going straight for
magnus's King we have Queen to A5 now
putting pressure on that C3 pawn and now
that Bishop to D2 movie that he played
against ponomario so here we have Queen
Ponte F5 chasing away the queen queen G3
and now Pawn to G4 and Magnus locks out
the the king side completely although uh
if Queen comes to H4 maybe the queen
could enter the game for the moment not
really all of the squares are being
covered so uh you know maybe maybe at
some point here we have the characters
and C5 and there is a game uh that was
played also in 2007 obviously was a
popular line in 2007 between Alexander
motile and Yuri Krupa the game ended in
a draw and it continued with Queen
characters and C5 but Magnus postpones
the capture he plays knight gt7 uh
develops the Knight and it is now as of
move 13 that we have a completely new
game so okay Bishop to D3
uh on a continuous development and okay
it's a pretty standard uh position
against the French you you have triple
pawns but what do you want to do uh
Queen chapters and C5 Island picks off
one of them uh Magnus picks off one of
them and now Knight the E2 continuing
development Knights the A5 now the
Knight can come to C4 if needed and now
Queen to F2 like I said you could play
Queen to H4 maybe hope for Queen F6 but
then rook h8 and the queen really has no
business being on H4 so that's why Anan
plays Queen to F2 he offers a queen
trade and Magnus obliges Queen captures
an F2 we have King captures and now
Bishop to D7 and now uh I will just
mention it once again if you are having
issues with notifications from YouTube
do join our telegram channel it's the
first link in the description below if
you use telegram you will receive an
instant notification when a video is
published so okay Ponte A4 also a very
standard move against the French we have
King to F7 and now Rook H to B1 putting
pressure on B7 so the Knight has to be
careful uh so B6 getting rid of this
tension and now Bishop to C1 now the
bishop is coming to A3 and will claim
this diagonal which is mostly the idea
behind Ponte A4 we have Knight eat the
C6 with Bishop to A3 and now Knight to
d8 now the other Knight is coming to B7
uh we have Bishop to B4 and just knight
uh D to B7 uh now of course uh you
cannot capture the pawns will not be
doubled but even if you could you're not
really looking forward to parting with
your Bishop pair that soon so here we
have Knight to D4 beautiful Central
Square for the Knight and the Rook H to
B8 we have Knights to B3 offering a
trade of knights and uh a Magnus
declines Knight to C4 and if Anand wants
to continue the game
uh he will have to well either repeat
The Possession night day for uh night
day five or he will have to capture on
D4 so here we have Bishop captures on D4
uh sorry uh on on c4d captures on C4 and
now Knight back to D4 we have rooked the
C8 uh and now Pawn to A5 uh so trying to
mess up with the pawn structure a little
bit uh but Pawn to B5 by Magnus and now
Rook to D1 we have Bishop to A8 and now
Knight to E2 re-maneuvering the Knight
we have Pawn to A6 now you don't have to
worry about the queen side anymore and
Rook the D4 preparing to double up Rooks
on the D file we have Rook to d8 and The
Rook 8 to D1 uh Magnus trades Here and
Now Rook captures on D4 probably you
would be expecting C captures on D4
because this un doubles your pawns uh
but after Bishop to C6 you really have
no hope of Crossing that the D5 Square
so it is a perhaps better to play Rook
captures on D4 and our good friend the
engine agrees with Bishop to C6 and now
Rook the D2 again you will have to be
careful you don't want to blunder the G2
Pawn so The Rook might also help help
out with that and now Magnus could just
uh you know move the Rook back and forth
but he goes for Pawn to G3 check he
offers a pawn sacrifice but it's not one
you are eager to accept because of
course if King captures then just Rook
to G8 check and then you pick up the GT
pawn and if Knight capture still works
the G8 now the Knight cannot move it's
uh well it's uh not the the passive
position you want to have so instead we
have King to G1
and now Rook the G8 with knights the D4
attacks the bishop and Rook to d8 pins
the Knight here we have Bishop to D6 uh
blocking this path and now Bishop to E4
uh if you play some like Knight captures
on D6 to try and win upon the Knight
captures and C6 wins the game as the
rook and the Knight are hanging here so
after Bishop to D6 with Bishop to E4 and
now Bishop to B4 we have Rook to D5 and
here The Rook will be nicely protected
it's on a light Square
out of the reach of the bishop and the
knight and king to F1 we have knighted
the d8 and now King the E1 we have
knighted the C6 and now comes Knight to
E2 sorry about
uh sorry about that got something in my
throat uh Knight to E2 and now uh well
uh this is a great a great attempt by
Iron because if you play King to F1 here
uh the problem is after let's say Knight
captures some b4c captures and C3 uh you
will uh lose material for example Rook
D1 Bishop captures and that's a problem
if Rook c one okay we just moved the
bishop the Knight is still hanging if
you move the Knight Pawn to C2
and the pawn is defended you have no way
out of this so after night they do we
have Rook captures and the two King
captures and now Bishop captures on G2
Knight captures and G3 and now Bishop to
F3 now putting pressure on that pawn and
uh it's uh it's a question how will
Anand uh move the Knight if the Knight
has to guard that pawn well of course
you have to kick away the bishop King E3
Bishop to D1 and now you are putting
pressure on both of the pawns with the
bishop and this is uh uh quite
problematic for honor the way of King to
D2 uh Bishop to G4 now and King to E3 we
have King T8 and now King 32 can the
Knight who just remain on G3 and
everything will be okay uh well uh let's
check it out Knight the E7 was played
and now Bishop captures an E7 and uh
well he he does get the trade off some
material uh but that means that he's now
left with this Knight that cannot move
uh due to the fact that this Pawn will
just hang so King captors and King the
C1 now Anand will try getting his King
up the board uh but chances are Magnus
will not allow this we have King to D7
King to B2 King to C6 and now King the
A2 we have King to D5 King to A3 and now
King the C5 of course stopping King to
B4 King to B2 and now Bishop to D1 uh
the bishop is excellent on this diagonal
but if you just keep it on G4 it doesn't
look like you'll be able to make
progress with King to C1 and Bishop to
F3
uh King to B2 and now Magnus throws in a
nice Pawn to B4 we have C captures on B
for King to D4 now getting more axes
with the King Here pawn to C3 with check
and now King to D3 but this also means
that Anna now has Pawn to B5 and then uh
the a pawn is becoming a queen uh did
Magnus uh of course uh think of this es
he did as the bishop card d8 Square so
Pawn to B5 a captures on B5 Pawn to A6
and now King to D2 We have Pawn to A7 uh
and now Bishop to D5 and here uh Anand
uh it actually still has a good position
and he can draw this but he has to play
Knight to F1 check point is that after
King to D3 uh there's Knight back to G3
and now if you play B4 it's not a
problem see captures uh you're gonna
deliver a check uh and now uh sorry
another check you're gonna play uh King
to D2 and everything is uh fine now so
that's how you uh that's how you you
keep a draw here uh play something like
that to F1 check and we repeat the
process all over again the point is the
blacking cannot keep an eye on the C1
square or rather he can't control the C1
Square once you start pushing the C Pawn
because then white cannot play King to
C1 if white can play King to C1 black
cannot win he only has a light Square
Bishop you cannot kick away the white
king from a dark Square so that would be
the problem however I don't play Knight
captures on F5 and now uh e captures an
F5 uh this is uh I mean okay B4 is
always uh winning and even in this
position it is winning I can even show
it to you because it's a really crazy
line like B4 and now of course you
cannot capture we already discussed that
if the King Controls the C1 Square then
you're just gonna lose C to C1 but look
at this if Knight's the D4 then the win
is somewhat uh
uh more mysterious B captures on C3
check King to B1 now okay the Knight
controls C2 but it will play Bishop e
for check King moves and now C2 you will
win the White Knight and after Knight
captures King captures you will play F5
so you won't overload the bishop uh if
the bishop cannot control F5 and the A8
square but now you just Advance the C
pawn and now after captures you will
move the king and after E7 you will play
the bishop to D5 check King to A3 and
now Pawn to C2 we'll play E8 Queen now
comes C1 Queen and of course the bishop
and the queen will beat the queen
regardless of the pass Pawn here after a
few moves uh you will just hunt that
King at some point win the pawn with
check and then it's pretty
straightforward but okay Magnus played
for E captures and F5 which is
remarkably uh even an even stronger idea
now Anan plays E6 and now Pawn to B4 we
have Pawn to E7 uh B captures and C3
with check King to A2 and now C2 Anan
plays A8 Queen he wants to get the
bishop off of such an active square and
also he doesn't want C3 to come with
check so he gives up this queen to bring
another queen into the game we have E8
Queen and now we have Bishop to E4
interestingly C3 here is winning for
Magnus but both of them were extremely
low on time here so uh it's not the easy
finding such a move point is that once
of course uh well if you start checking
then at some point the bishop will be
able to cover up the the black king and
of course if you capture the bishop then
C1 Queen again comes with check and you
will
uh be able to win this game uh not come
with check Queen G2 check comes with
check and after the king moves uh a
couple of checks and then you will be
able to cover up with the queen and then
of course the past C Pawn will decide
the game but in the game Magnus played
Bishop to E4 both of them like I said
under extreme time pressure Queen to d8
check Bishop to D3 and now Anand has
only one way to draw the game and it's I
mean it's so so silly to even think
about finding this scene in time trouble
and that is Queen to B6 point is that
after C1 uh queen or doesn't really
matter uh you will play Queen to E3
check and white is in uh stalemate the
oppon covers this square and the queen
covers all the other squares uh if you
capture a stalemate if you move you just
force the capture even Queen D to check
whatever black plays uh it's still gonna
be
um a stalemate but Anand played Queen to
D4 it's the same idea Anand is preparing
Queen to E3 with check but now there's a
big difference so feel free to pause the
video and win the game for Magnus while
I give you a couple of seconds
foreign
this uh only uh only winning idea and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is of course C1 night uh
Magnus brings the Knight into the game
with check and now the game is
completely winning the problem is here
of course if you ring the queen into the
game then again Queen the C3 check and
this will be stalemate so uh we we've
already seen this but after C1 Knight
check uh it's a different story now what
can what can you play here of course you
can play King A1 King to B2 King to A3
whatever you play if King A1 then I'd be
three check just connects nicely with
the queen uh Royal Fork happening there
if uh King to beat you then it's a bit
of a longer win night day two chases
away the queen and after the queen moves
you just Advance the pawn because you
control all of these squares you just
don't care C2 then okay you can give a
check block the pawn a little bit you
can uh here okay there are better moves
than uh playing King 31 but you don't
have to do it you can even do this you
can give up the Knight to trade queens
and your extra piece will still win the
game here so really it's a non-brainer
and after King the A3 which Anand played
in the game now Pawn to C3 by Magnus
Queen to B6 and now Knight to E2 we have
Queen captures on H6 creating a pass
Pawn which could be very relevant and
now has plans of uh stopping the pass
Pawn by sacrificing the queen and then
promoting his past H Pawn to a queen C2
and now Queen to B6 and here uh
incredible as it may sound Magnus did
not play C1 Queen this comes with check
and Magnus did not play it that's it you
can uh imagine how how intense the game
was if Magnus did not play this maybe he
just didn't think of it I don't know
instead he played Knight to C1 and now
Anand is the one who is in a better
position because now Magnus has to waste
another move uh to get the Knight out of
the C1 Square promote then I will
sacrifice the queen and then will you be
able to stop the past H Pawn uh I don't
know because Queen the C6 was played and
now Knight the two and it was in this
position on move 72 that vishwanathan
Anand lost on time and I mean what what
what a game uh here the problem is uh
it's not the same okay you do get a
queen but it's now anand's move H6 and
okay you do get a queen but now uh Anand
happily gives up the queen queen
captures Knight captures H7 and after
Knight day two h8 queen you will pick up
the F4 pawn and yes you still have the
Knight and Bishop you have a past Pawn
it's even a protected pass Pawn but now
uh the pass Pawn is too far away for you
to do anything it will be either either
black draws this or white just wins this
as well as usual an incredible showing
by both of them uh Anand and Magnus
always always deliver the absolute best
chess in here they did so once again uh
you know uh we could say you know
someone was luckier here someone wasn't
but uh you know they say that luck luck
favors the strong and the Magnus indeed
was the was the stronger player here uh
sure that's the game I hope you guys
enjoyed it uh I would like to thank
Thomas eternally or Rob Carroll UI uh
you you see uh felico Torres
Dan McCormick and James Eugene Cashman
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
sorry about my throat issues I think
they are getting much much better I
think maybe like a day or two at most uh
and I will be you know once again fully
operational see you soon